there is a potential disaster that we
have to avert among the Democratic
National Committee and the Democratic
Party former vermont governor Howard
Dean says he is running for his old job
atop the Democratic Party Dean tweeted
on Thursday the dems need organization
and focus on the young need a 50-state
strategy and tech rehab I am in for
chairman again now you might remember
that from 2005 2009 Howard Dean was
indeed chairman of the Democratic
National Committee right now Donna
Brazile is serving as interim chairwoman
after the disgrace debbie Wasserman
Schultz step down right before the
democratic national convention in
Philadelphia I don't want to speak I
don't want lack of clarity right out to
channel Phil Davison I want clarity this
evening Howard Dean again as president
as chair of the DNC would be a disaster
for Democrats do not put Howard Dean in
that position now before I get into the
details of why now let me remind you
when Howard Dean became a healthcare
lobbyists and all of a sudden was
against the single-payer healthcare he
had been for most of his uh political
life remember this video take a listen
to this if I could interject his referee
vermona strikes me that the the sort of
legitimate good faith attack is to say
look it was really hard to pass the ACA
opening up a fight on health care
politically could backfire which is the
most charitable version of what Chelsea
Clinton saying as opposed to the idea
that like Bernie Sanders gonna try to
take away your health care which seems
implausible I don't think well I mean
yes I a bracer in senator certainly had
no intention of his health care the
question is would his plan result in the
kind of chaos trying to implement it
that in fact would undo people's health
care that somebody people should be
concerned about look we're never going
to have a sensible debate about this
between now and the convention it isn't
going to happen there's too much
politics in it right but in fact is this
is the classic race of the visionary and
the pragmatist and I've chosen the
pragmatist right our Dean thank you very
much his explanation as to why Bernie
Sanders and his ideas are just not good
so not labeled by the way as a lobbyist
but showed up there and said yeah then
not really something we want to do
and then again on MSNBC again not
labeled as a lobbyist equated super PACs
to labor unions which is such a bogus
and depraved comparison but here's what
he did show herself to be so closely
dried financially this girl's got
mentioned on Morning Joe the other day
and I said well I didn't think she'd
done this and Joe went and found out you
know that she's given speeches to
colleges for example it turned out that
money it was either put up by donors and
had nothing to do the colleges and a lot
of it was given back to the Clinton
Foundation which is a major charity
which has done great things for people
all over the world why does Hillary
Clinton have to put up with a double
standard I don't hear anybody asking
bernie sanders for his transcripts for
some speech he made with the labor union
and this have been even pregnant for
Bernie to say that he doesn't have a
super PAC labor unions are super PACs
now they're super PACs the Democrats
like so we don't go after Labor you Wow
but this is a double standard I am tired
of the attacks on Hillary Clinton's
integrity yeah well he's tired we're
still putting together our plan for the
next few years and already the Democrats
are at risk of going backwards even more
this is a path backwards for Democrats
this is what ruined 2016 for Democrats
the selection of sort of establishment
center center right of ideas I've been
reading comments like hey wait but
Howard Dean was the architect of the
2008 Obama victory and the Democratic
supermajority different situation we
would need to hear expressions of
interest in involving less established
and more progressive members of
government slamming Bernie for being in
support of single-payer health care is
not sending the message Pat that the
Democrats understand what went wrong in
2016 and this will send a clear and
resounding message that were done with
people like debbie Wasserman Schultz and
Donna Brazil's and Hillary Clinton's we
want a true progressive to take over as
the DNC chair well political reported or
late last week that Vermont senator
Bernie Sanders is backing congressman
keith Ellison from Minnesota to be DNC
chair Ellison was a top surrogate for
Sanders during the primary and
moveon.org also released a statement
saying the DNC needs
clean house Alison would make an
excellent chairman that is a more
reasonable idea now there are green
partiers in Jill Stein supporters who
are saying David where I'm against this
Ellison is not left enough you got under
one percent of the vote after a non-stop
campaign about how great Jill Stein is
no one at the Green Party is ready to
lead I would not be taking any direction
from from the Green Party but I would
also not be taking any direction from
the establishment DNC people all of whom
deserve to be fired I can't justify
anyone at the DNC keeping their job
after what happened during the 2016 race
and putting Howard Dean in there who
showed up a lobbyist not labeled as such
on on TV multiple times to defend
Hillary Clinton's establishment ideas
and trash burning no absolutely not do
not take the step backwards if you are
the DNC and this is going to be high on
our list of agenda items going forward
we'll take a break